salut nous sommes dimanche c'est donc le
jour de l'explication de la semaine et
c'est la 52e vidéo du mental blog je
vais vous expliquer quatre techniques
qui permettent d'aboutir un seul et même
résultat à savoir dans quelles mains et
cacher un objet vous allez pouvoir
demander à quelqu'un de cacher un objet
dans sa main et vous serez en mesure de
savoir dans quelles mains c et en
variant les techniques comme ça c'est
indécelable essai imparable à la fin de
cette vidéo j'ai une grosse annonce à
vous faire une question à vous poser
donc n'oubliez pas de bien regarder la
vidéo jusqu'au bout parce que je vais
avoir besoin de vous de votre avis et
puis c'est surtout un truc à vous
annoncer
explication donc de quatre techniques
pour savoir dans quelles mains et cacher
un objet sur quelqu'un pour jouer à dans
quelles mains mais version mentalist a
tout d'abord prenez un objet est
quelqu'un qui a demain je vais prendre
un objet classique un des as en face si
toi aussi tu passé des nuits à jouer à
donjons et dragons avec tes potes envoie
potes âgés pas de potes parce qu'en
général quand on fait des jeux de rôle
on n'a pas trop de potes premier conseil
s'est pas vraiment d'explication mais
premier conseil demandez quand même à la
personne de prendre un objet
relativement conséquents prenez pas une
pièce de monnaie trop petit ou ce genre
de choses en tout cas pas pour commencer
après quand vous serez bien entraînés
vous pourrez prendre des tout petits
objets et deuxième petite astuce soyez
bien clair et bien précis quant aux
indications vous allez donner à la mi à
qui vous fait sa première technique et
donc première explication pour la
première technique vous demandez à votre
ami de m l'objet dans une de ces je vais
prendre autre chose parce que alors ça
ça va vite nous saouler du coup j'en ai
pris un vraiment normal un dé à 8 face
vous demandez donc à votre ami de m
l'objet dans une de ses deux mains vous
vous retournez pour pas voir ce que la
personne fait quand vous êtes retourné
vous pouvez symboliser les gestes vaut
aussi pour qu'ils puissent comprendre
vous lui dites qu une fois que c'est
fait il met la main qui contient l'objet
comme ceux ci sur son front et qui se
concentre sur elle il faut qu'ils se
concentrent absolument sûr la main le
plus longtemps possible qu'ils
vieillissent bien l'objet et qui à
l'intérieur de sa main et vous allez le
faire tenir comme ça en parlant plus
vous le fait tenir longtemps et mieux
c'est une fois que c'est fait il doit
mettre les deux mains devant lui comme
ça alors pas trop sur le côté elle a
fait pour que vous puissiez bien voir et
vous prévenir que c'est fait je
récapitule y met un objet dans sa main
il met la main comme ça au niveau de son
front vous le fait tenir on veut fait
compter jusqu'à 15
une fois que c'est fait il doit mettre
les deux mains comme ça et vous prévenir
qu'il est prêt dès qu'il me dit que
c'est prêt vous vous retournez et vous
regardez tout de suite c'est demain tout
de suite tout de suite c'est très
important parce que durant quelques
secondes
l'une dès demain va être plus pâle que
l'autre c'est la main qui contient
l'objet en lui faisant mettre la main
comme ça durant 'assez longtemps' vous
allez faire descendre le sens lama sera
moins bien irrigué que l'autre main qui
elle pas en vers le bas et au moment où
il va détendre devant lui y'en a un qui
a un afflux sanguin moins conséquent
donc aller plus pâle donc c'est la main
qui contient l'objet et là je pense
qu'on voit clairement la différence
entre la main que j'avais mis sur le
front et l'autre c'est une première
technique très efficace mais j'en ai
d'autres j'en ai d'autres pour vous
deuxième technique
l'indication par le nez on appelle ça le
nose n'ose donc ça veut dire le nez
c'est en fait le nez c'est une seule
chose c'est pas une technique qui est
fiable non plus à 100 % mais vous allez
vite vous y adapter et souvent vous en
servir vous demander à la personne de
mettre le nez dans une de ses deux mains
de mettre les mains dans son dos de
mélanger et vous de l'autre côté vous
comptez jusqu'à 3 quand vous avais dit
le mot 3 la personne doit attendre les
deux points comme ça devant elle et
penser à son objet en même temps il se
passe quelque chose de très sensible
c'est que le fait de penser à la main
qui contient l'objet moi c'est la main
droite
ça fait pointer le bout de son nez vers
la bonne main c'est pour ça qu'on dit
the nose noz il vous suffit donc de
regarder dans quel axe va aller le nez
en fait le nez c'est parce que la tête
pointe légèrement mais vous pouvez
prendre cet axe là la variation est très
sensible mais si vous demandez à la
personne de penser à son objet pendant
qu'elle tend les mains vers vous alors
ce sera beaucoup plus lisible troisième
explication troisième technique bande de
petits veinards si vous êtes des petits
veinards parce que là à l'heure où je
fais la vidéo vous êtes encore dans
votre lit que je le sais je vous vois
c'est le trou vous regardez même la
vidéo depuis le lit pas enfin cette
troisième technique elle demande un tout
petit peu d'entraînement et elle
nécessite donc que l'objet soit
relativement gros dans la main vous
demander comme d'habitude à la personne
de maître l'objet dans une de ses deux
mains de tendre les deux points comme ça
vers vous et vous allez prendre le pouls
de chaque poignet en même temps donc
pour prendre un poussin plein vous
mettez deux doigts de souhaits un doigt
dessus et vous faites pareil donc voulu
donner deux poignées en même temps et
vous allez ressentir les variations mais
pour réussir à sentir cette variation il
faut ce qu'on appelle un calibrage au
départ donc avant de donner l'objet à la
personne vous
prenez les poux comme ceci vous essayez
de voir caler son rythme naturel quelles
sont ces crispations naturel vous lui
donnez l'objet la personne elle met les
mains dans son dos elle mélange haletant
comme ça vous reprenez les deux en même
temps en temps normal il n'y aura pas
encore de variations et là vous l'a
perturbé oui demandé de se concentrer
sur son objet comme s'il était en train
de chauffer de vraiment ressentir toutes
les sensations tout le texture de
l'objet à l'intérieur de sa main et plus
elle va y penser plus elle va avoir des
micromouvements musculaire et une petite
variation dans son coup vous allez
sentir ça c'est très dur à expliquer
avec des mots mais si vous essayez de le
faire vous allez ressentir ces
variations là elles sont très
intéressantes
c'est une troisième technique vous
pouvez l'essayer c'est bluffant même
vous vous allez vous bluffez vous même
et la quatrième et dernière explication
pour aujourd'hui pour ce dimanche c'est
celle des yeux vous allez regarder la
variation dans la dilatation de la
rétine simplement la dilatation pas ou
par le regard juste la dilatation de la
rétine donc vous avez la personne qui
est en face de vous vous devez bien
regarder comment sont ses yeux à l'état
naturel à l'état normal c'est-à-dire
avec la luminosité qu'elle se prend
essayer d'être dans une configuration où
la lumière va rester fixes tels qu allez
vous demander quoi à la personne va vous
lui demandez de m l'objet dans sa main
parce que c'est quand même un petit peu
le but de jeu de départ deux mélanges et
de tendre les points vers vous mais en
vrai on s'en fiche un petit peu des
points ce moment là ce qui vous
intéresse c'est leur regard de la
personne et vous lui dites si l'objet
est dans ta main droite alors j'aimerais
que tu es une image précise en tête
l'image de toit sur une plage en plein
soleil
mais tu as chaud hein tu as beaucoup
trop chaud et en plein soleil et tu
regardes ce soleil qui de cogne qui te
colle guy decock et a pas le choix tu es
juste là c'est un peu comme des grandes
dunes de sahara est tout de suite vous
complétez en disant par contre si
l'objet dans ta main gauche alors
j'aimerais que tu t'imagines dans la rue
en pleine nuit fait nos nuits noires
étaient en train de rentrer chez toi
avec une personne très très très sexy si
la personne est marié vous pouvez dire
que c'est sa femme ou son mari un mois
je veux pas d'embrouillés 1 par rapport
à ça répéter en boucle de bien se
concentrer sur son image et uniquement
sur son image
parce que départ la personne va
forcément penser aux deux choses que
vous avez dit ça c'est complètement
normal on n'a pas le choix par exemple
si je vous dis ne pensez surtout pas ce
que vous avez à faire lundi
il profitait de vote dimanche là qu'est
ce que vous faites vous pensez à ce que
vous allez faire lundi c'est comme ça
que fonctionne le cerveau il connaît pas
la négation et pour contrer ça vous lui
demandez bien de se concentrer sur son
image et uniquement sur son image de
vraiment se concentré mentalement
d'imaginer cette scène la nourrir un
maximum et vous pendant ce temps là vous
occultez ses yeux pas la loupe parce que
vous le voyez bien ça plaît beaucoup
trop peur mais vous regardez vous êtes
attentif et vous allez voir d'une
manière sensible mais assez précise si
la pupille se dilate ou si elle se
rétracte
si la publie se rétracte légèrement où
beaucoup d'ailleurs ou fortement c'est
que la personne est en train de
s'imaginer en train de regarder le
soleil est en tout cas dans un paysage
très lumineux puisque quand on a de la
lumière la pupille serait très vous
pouvez faire l'expérience vous pouvez
même vous regardez devant un miroir et
allumé la torche de votre téléphone et
la mettre devant vos yeux et là vous
allez voir ça devient tout petit et au
contraire cela pupilles se dilatent
c'est que la personne est en train de
s'imaginer plutôt dans le noir et le
fait d'avoir ajouté quelqu'un de très
sexy c'est pas du tout anodin c'est
parce que ça provoque un petit peu
d'excitation et l'excitation saf et
dilatés ce qui est vraiment intéressant
c'est qu'aujourd'hui je vous ai pas
donné une explication mais quatre
explications et vous allez pouvoir les
varié où les associés pour être sûr ne
pas vous tromper parce que si vous
trouvez l'objet qu'il ya dans une main
c'est peut-être un hasard il ya une
chance sur deux mais si ces deux fois
d'affilée trois fois d'affilée 4 x 5 x
ou à tous les coups alors là c'est plus
du hasard n'y a qu'une seule solution
c'est que vous n'êtes pas ta liste
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plus que
vous allez vous servir de ça peut-être
même pour bluffer les gens tout à
l'heure à votre repas à midi ou ce soir
ou dans la semaine pour bluffer vos amis
en cours ou au travail où je sais pas où
n'importe où avant de vous dire ce que
j'avais à vous dire
n'oubliez pas si vous avez aimé cette
vidéo de la partager de parler de la
chaîne aux gens que vous connaissez pour
qui s'abonnent à 2500 abonnés je vous le
rappelle c'est mon objectif
on se fait un apéro virtuel en ligne
c'était on va faire un live de deux
heures on sera chacun chez nous on se
verra ans par laurence réécrira on va
faire des trucs durant deux ou trois
heures j'en sais rien en live en vidéo
et j'ai vraiment hâte que ça arrive et
quand se rencontrent comme ça par
caméras interposées
d'ailleurs si vous n'êtes pas abonné
abonnez vous tout de suite à la chaîne a
oui je suis bête moi je pars du principe
que si vous regardez la vidéo c'est que
vous êtes abonné mais peut-être pas donc
abonnez vous à cette chaîne vous en
supplie et la fameuse annonce qu'est ce
que c'est au delà même d'une annonce
c'est d'abord et avant tout une question
aujourd'hui on
1515 abonné je crois sur la chaîne je
vous pose la question à vous tous le
1515 et si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné
vous vous abonner et répond à la
question que vous pose j'ai encore envie
de lancer un nouveau format sur ce
mental vlog donc au départ c'était juste
une vidéo par jour où je mentalise est
quelqu'un en fait que je rencontrais
depuis le mercredi et les astuces le
dimanche qui a une explication comme on
vient de le faire
le samedi il ya les master classes qui
sont des vidéos un peu plus longues sur
un sujet un peu plus poussée ou faut
bosser en faut être en clair chez soi
pour pouvoir assimiler ça j'ai envie de
lancer un nouveau truc le g mais je sais
pas si ça va vous plaire vraiment c'est
toujours dans l'esprit du mental vlog
mais ça se rapproche quand même plus du
podcast en fait il ya plein de trucs qui
me passionne vous vous en rendrez compte
dans la vidéo je suis en permanence je
le vois c'est moi qui montre la vidéo
je me vois dire alors ça ça me passionne
alors ça j'adore sa rage et des jeux
blizzard j'arrête pas de dire ça parce
que c'est vrai je suis passionné par
plein de choses et j'aimerais vous en
parlait en fait sans forcément qui est
un fondamentalisme derrière juste pour
vous faire découvrir les trucs qui me
font marrer qui m'interpelle qui
m'intéresse bien qu'ils auraient
toujours un lien avec mes centres
d'intérêt mes centres d'intérêt il
tourne autour du mentalisme mais la
vraie question c'est est-ce que ça peut
potentiellement vous plaire en fait est
ce que vous allez pas vous dire ah ben
non ça on voulait pas ça dites moi dites
moi dans les commentaires dites moi sur
les réseaux sociaux dit moi sur facebook
sur twitter sur instagram sur ce match
at on appris le reste sur périscope sur
vine sur wii je suis sûr tous ces trucs
là oui mais dites le moi avant jeudi
prochain quand même passé un excellent
dimanche bluffé bien tout le monde avec
toutes ces techniques là et rendez vous
demain à 17 heures pour le prochain
mentale vlog ciao